welcome everybody to the data science
hangout
um welcome back to all the familiar
faces
uh i think most people who are on now
have joined before but if this is your
first one this is an open
space for current and aspiring data
science leaders to just connect and
learn from each other
so we don't have an agenda for the the
calls or focuses on questions that are
most important to you all
so there's three ways that you can ask
questions you could jump in live put
questions in the zoom chat
or we also have a slido so you can ask
anonymous questions too
and just want to point out that this
session will be recorded
and shared up to youtube
as well
but i'm so excited to be joined by my
co-host for today
paul ditterline director of data science
at heaven hill brands
and paul i think
if it's okay with you just turn it over
to you to maybe have you introduce
yourself and share a bit about your team
and the work that you do
yeah sure so hey everybody um like
rachel said my name is paul and i'm the
director of data science at heaven hill
we make um some of the best spirits in
the world so you've probably heard of
things like evan williams and elijah
craig and some other cool products like
hypnotic
we do a we make a lot of cool products
at heaven hill
from a data science perspective um it's
really cool because
we are a really work consumer package
goods company and we have production
facilities and we have things like
shipping and then we also have things
like um
marketing and sales and infrastructure
to support the end-to-end production and
sales of um of our products so there's a
lot of cool opportunity there for data
science
in every aspect of that process and so
i lead a team called data services
under the leadership of a relatively new
cio
that's really trying to tackle this
head-on and build a data science
foundation
really from the foundation level which
includes how our erp system and data
systems
are organized and communicate
all the way up through how we can pull
analytics out of those systems and
derive business value that we can easily
communicate
to the business so that's i think that's
kind of a nutshell what my team does
awesome and as we're waiting for
questions to come in
from the from the audience i think it'd
be cool to to hear from you what's
something that you're really excited
about in data science right now
yeah so i've kind of got a few answers
for that you know that's a really broad
question to me if i think about it
locally in my current work i'm really
excited about the foundational work
we're doing from an iet level
to make it easier to do data science
right like what how do we get all these
disparate systems to more easily talk to
each other and provide the raw material
of data to our analysts so that we can
we can spend less time munging and more
time you know providing insight which i
know is like the bane of every single
data scientist uh probably that exist
today
um a little bit if i step back a second
from that um i'm excited about tools
like gpt3 and how they might change the
type of products that we can make i've
been on the waiting list for like i
think it was like a year and i recently
got access so i've been really
excited about thinking about how i can
use um you know large neural networks
like that in my own work and what sort
of value i can use with this i would say
relatively new uh tool that you know
i've never had access to before aside
from things that i could train
and then i i regularly just sort of geek
out on upcoming packages and
functionality especially within the
rstudio set of products so there's a
really cool resource called our weekly
that i checked kind of religiously
usually at the end of reading that i've
got like 30 open tabs that are
recent papers that people have published
or upcoming packages or changes to
packages or blog posts about how to use
some packages i'm interested in like
most recently
i've gotten into using blastula
connected our markdown to try to move
away from like go-to dashboards to more
automated exception-based reporting that
informs whenever something happens so
instead of having to go to dig for
something people sort of get that hand
delivered to them and using tools like
the connect api package which is
relatively new has been really cool to
build those types of things
awesome sorry a little over the place
there
no that that's great um i see there's a
question in the slido that
speaks to what you you mentioned earlier
since data services is under the cio is
it relatively easy for your team to get
what you need from it
yeah this was a really big learning for
me
actually my previous employer i spent
seven years at brown foreman
um starting off in r d
as an analyst and at the end of my
career there i i was helping implement
the global advanced analytics function
and one problem that i noticed there was
traditional i.t was sort of this thing
and then data science was like this
this other thing
and sometimes those two things collided
in ways that
weren't the best in terms of agility in
terms of like implementing the data
science solution so one of the things i
pushed for at heaven hill uh when we got
the new cio was
trying to put all those things into one
vertical and and the answer is yes like
having the folks that sort of build
those data platforms uh build those
pipelines
with the analytics and the data science
needs in mind has been incredibly
helpful yeah and i i and from my
experience i would highly recommend some
sort of integration along those lines
from a business perspective
cool and i know you just so you just
mentioned about working at brown foreman
as well so i think it might be helpful
for the audience or some of the aspiring
data science leaders to understand um
like where you started there at brown
foreman and then also how you got into
leadership as well and and what your
journey looks like
yeah um
you know i i think that using
one of the things that that i like about
r um and our studio is really
it's the packages and the functionality
but it's also the community and the and
the openness and how do i use this
and years ago like what a decade ago now
or when i was starting off there as as
just an analyst a new person who really
wanted to make an impact
i was able to do a lot more than i think
i could have
because of the tools that existed in the
r community so
instead of doing like one-off analysis
and providing an answer i was able to
say learn shiny and spin up an
application that solved that problem not
just once but over time and i was able
to use those free open source tools to
to come to my leadership at the time and
say hey
if we had x we could solve problems this
way
and over years of building that i was
able to sort of push
push that strategy and push the thinking
into that direction so really it was
just um
using the tools that were available
to
show a vision with tangible assets that
people could understand
and then leading that into sort of what
the vision for data science could be in
the future and that's what kind of got
me from doing it at the ground level to
helping lead
the implementation of that so but
without those tools i think it would
have been really hard to try to do
something like that
and i know i know that's something that
a lot of people are probably going
through now like from being a data
analyst and trying to
like can i sell the idea of data science
internally as well so i'm sure there'll
be some follow-up questions there
um but bruno i see you asked a question
in the chat and i'd love to hand the mic
over to you if you want to ask it live
sure
thanks for doing this paul uh retail is
pretty interesting how do you tackle the
whole
data
the data along the supply chain
up to the retail store do you get like
very
fine data
details or
can you can you uh
i don't know put process in place to
gather more information
so it's a little interesting with with
alcohol sales in america we have what's
called a a three-tiered system where
we're not allowed to sell directly to
the store that sells it to you this is a
prohibition
um
legal effect that's been in place since
then so we essentially have to sell two
distributors who then sell to individual
stores so
that does create you know some
difficulty in sort of getting that data
however we do have really good
partnerships with those distributors and
we are able to get um
at the store daily not really
transaction level what's what's being
shipped from them into the stores so
at
it's kind of a headache because you have
to deal with like what we're shipping to
this third party and then what they're
shipping to a consumer right so it's
like two different sets of metrics
but we are kind of lucky that we have we
can get to that store level data but we
have a lot of um
creative assets in play to try to try to
get us that information as as quickly
and as at the lowest level possible it's
not always easy
chris i see you asked a question as well
around
how much of what the what work is being
done is through cloud services
chris
do you want to add any other contacts
there
uh yeah um again like everyone says
thanks paul for doing this always
appreciate having these
guest data scientists coming in to do
this
um
so
i i work i work with
air force um mainly uh special operation
command stuff and all that and one of
the challenges that we have within our
data science community is
you know
the traditional things like you talked
about before where you have your your
siloed information and stuff like that
and now they're talking about um
you know the possibility
of working in uh cloud environments and
that and i just wanted to get your take
as to whether or not you and your team
are doing more of your analytics uh
on a cloud basis
compared to the normal data styles that
you see in a lot of companies
yeah so from a from a data perspective
from that end we're definitely mostly
on-prem uh we're in the middle of a
strategy again i mentioned we got a new
ceo and uh i'm sorry a new cio in uh in
january
and he's implemented a strategy that
does include sort of a cloud-based
future and we're in the process of
moving it from a data perspective
from an analytics perspective
we're in the process of moving to
that traditional
emailing each other excel files
analytics to a more um
i kind of think of it as two different
pathways
i want a pathway for someone who writes
code and r or python or whatever i need
them to be successful i need them to
connect to data sources create products
easily post them to some web-based
outcome one source of truth you know get
backed up all of that but then i need a
more
what i might call an analyst
professional someone who
needs a more modern tool from excel
needs to provide that web-based
experience
and isn't going to learn how to code so
you know that's like maybe a tableau or
a power bi right so we're transitioning
um into setting up the uh the
infrastructure we need to support both
of those we've already got our studio
team implemented uh on-prem for the data
science side and that's working well for
us and we're probably moving to power bi
for the um for the analyst side because
we're we're also a microsoft company
that's just kind of you know um who we
use for our tech solution
so um yeah so i guess to succinctly
answer that nearly all on-prem now but
with a
with a current um strategy that's in
progress to move to the cloud in the
next let's say five years
okay thank you
yeah
thanks paul
there are a few anonymous questions
coming in on slido too and and one is
what is something that is impacted by
data science in your industry that you
might not expect
so
one one thing that comes to mind um
is barrel yield
so if you some people might not know
much about about spirits right
i'm a little biased because i live in
kentucky and here everybody knows about
bourbon because it's the famous saying
that there are more you know barrels of
bourbon than there are kentuckians um
well when you make when you make a
whiskey or bourbon you make a distillate
and you put it in a barrel and if you've
never seen one of these barrels they're
they're really big they hold about 55
gallons of liquid and then they go into
a warehouse and when they're full they
weigh about 500 pounds and they sit in a
warehouse for um you know four to 12 to
even longer years
and of course due to evaporation and
soakage and
maybe
issues with barrels you're going to have
some amount of liquid left in that
barrel whenever you go to dump it
and
as you might imagine especially if
you're in finance the you know a couple
percent changes in that amount
that's a big deal i mean that's product
that you thought you would have that you
don't have so
using some cool data science methods
to get data from places that i wouldn't
have really expected to feed that into
models that can help predict what yields
are going to be was something i didn't
think would work but that did and and
that's a really cool thing that we use
in our business
that's so cool and what's your favorite
bourbon
oh man um i've always liked um elijah
craig since before i came to heaven hill
elijah craig rye got whiskey advocates
number seven last year they do like a
blind test every year and ranked them
all but our larceny our barrel proof
larceny which is a weeded bourbon got
number one actually so that's been
pretty popular but i'm an elijah craig
fan
going back to uh packages there's a
another anonymous question what packages
do you use most for modeling and machine
learning
is it primary tidy models and related or
do you also use python
why yeah so i i like tidy models i like
the framework there um
i actually i i came up in base r so if
i'm doing like a logistic regression or
a
linear model i mean i got to be honest
oftentimes i'll bang it out quickly and
based our before i move on to like a
tidy model framework
um
for like machine learning and deep
learning um i use the keras and
tensorflow packages
um
that's what we have in production now
for the model for the models that we're
using and stepping out a bit from
machine learning the tidy verse is
always like the first thing that i call
pretty much everything that i'm doing um
i i live in our markdown
i think that unless you're doing
something that's very very small and
one-off you should almost always start
your work at our markdown because the
point of the work you're doing is
probably going to be to communicate
something and you're going to end up
doing double work you're going to
probably write a script and then maybe
you would open
god forbid word or something like that
to like
make a report while you're writing your
code but if you come with that in mind
you can open our markdown start it off
as a report do your analytical work
organize it and at the end of the day
you've pushed a button you have a
beautiful html web page with a floating
table of contents code chunks that fold
in and out you can also use python or r
or sql or d3 or other languages within
those chunks and then if you have team
you can push button to host that to team
shoot someone url and now you have a one
source of truth hosted report that
anyone can go to that you can control
access to and you did all that in one
markdown script so our markdown is just
completely invaluable for the work that
i do
we're actually looking at trying to take
some of our etl work directly into
a markdown base like a notebook-based
format just because
the documentation and the scheduling and
all that kind of comes along for the
ride whenever you whenever you do that
work um i like shiny a lot but i'm also
a big fan of flex dashboard
because it's really lightweight it's
really fast uh you can write your you
can write your like reactive code right
there instead of kind of having code in
the server and then referring to that
code in the ui
if it's something small um something
very quick i mean i i can go from
nothing to a hosted flex dashboard with
reactives in like an hour and a half and
so if i need something very fast i will
use that the other really cool thing
about flex dashboard is if you're not
using reactivity you can actually and
you don't have a way to host
applications to sort of show the value
of what you're doing you can email the
resulting knitted html the flex
dashboard to someone and when they open
it it opens like a beautiful web page
that's interactive for them and that's a
really cool way to share content if you
don't yet have the ability to to publish
and host stuff and i actually took
advantage of that at brown for foreman
to try to show people uh what you can do
with our tools
um
if i think of little things like
luberdate is like man i'm always using
the day for dates because i hate dealing
with dates so much
um
so yeah those are those are the those
are the main ones that come to mind
there's like a thousand more i'm sure
that's just what's in my brain right now
thank you i see in the chat there's a
lot of conversation going on around our
markdown
and shannon i think you asked a great
question earlier if um you want to jump
in as well
yeah i was just curious i mean you said
you live in our markdown so as a
director are you writing code daily
um i'm not writing code daily i'm
writing code um weekly and that's that's
one of the uh that's one of the issues
uh
most people probably have it um i
definitely have it personally is as you
move into more managerial or leadership
roles
you know your value tends to be derived
from
from just that from your leadership
right not so much from the code uh
i i don't want to lose that capability
so um i do try to dive in and help on
projects uh submit pull requests do that
sort of thing and i i have a pretty
strong opinion about how to do
data science so i don't want to be like
a micro manager type of person but you
know if someone's doing a bunch of
filtering and they're not using d player
i'm probably going to make a comment on
so this is stuff like that
yeah
frank it looks like you and paul are in
the same library with your backgrounds
oh yeah
funny enough i was just trying to figure
out what common books we have on our
bookshelf
he's actually here next to me we just
have two computers by myself
yeah
um just scrolling through um
to see some of the questions that were
asked in the chat if the rstudio team
would be able to help me just organize a
little bit but um
steve i see that you commented a bit on
using our markdown as well
we'd love to kind of open it up to
the audience as well if you have things
to share about the way you use our
markdown 2.
tony uh just asked the question
around internal packages paul and and
ask how many internal packages do you
host
right so i only have one internal
package currently um
i mean i i see a world where
there's a handful of those um for our
use case i think i think i think that'd
be about it
although to be fair um i know that
movement toward like package-based
development especially with things like
golem is you know um
it's pretty huge right now and i haven't
dug into it enough but i we have found
it helpful just to create helper
packages for commonly used functions for
sort of data munching or modeling that
we tend to do on a regular basis
i see ian asked a question earlier as
well and said he's in a noisy office so
i'll read the question
but do any of your analytics and data
science rely on
a vip a third-party vendor for the
beverage industry for your distributor
data
said the reason i ask is i'd like to
hear your insights on taking and
consuming data from third-party vendors
that you can't get an api into
so yeah
yes so so we you know in the earlier
question about sort of data at that
distributor and the retail level you
know i i made a joke about some creative
solutions and
you do kind of have these
vendors that have um
i'm not sure what the right phrase is um
historic
methods of getting data to you and
oftentimes there's not a lot you can do
about that so we just try to
automate that in the um
in the best way possible that fits our
infrastructure and doesn't require a lot
of human interaction to to bring that
data into our environment
i think that's all i can say about about
that
but we do work with vip data yeah
i know that's something that
we talked about with the team at the
city of reykjavik as well and
understanding their story that i would
have never thought about um like making
sure that certain like
tools that you purchase or other vendors
allow you to get access to the data
or like
that that's part of your contract
and it's something i wouldn't have
considered before
i i see zach you asked um i was curious
i guess it's because of paul and frank's
backgrounds but if you have all-time
favorite books
yeah i i guess like um
with a library like that i figure you
probably have like way too many but i'm
jealous of the the book of walls so
would definitely be curious if you guys
have any favorites
we got paul
you need to go first okay well it's hard
if i think like all-time favorites like
um all-time favorites like uh
meditations by marcus aurelius is
probably i don't know maybe my favorite
book of all time i think there's
reading that book and thinking about the
problems that this um guy was dealing
with
you know hundreds of years before i was
born and how it how it
intervenes into the life that i live
today has just always fascinated me and
i'm a fan of stoicism in general i
really like ryan holiday's recent books
um on uh the obstacle is the way an ego
is the enemy i think those are really
really good books um sort of from a
completely different perspective i
really love carlo rivelli's recent books
on business on on physics in general
his uh five brief lessons and physics is
fantastic and you can read that in like
20 minutes and his most recent book
called helgoland hegoland is about um
it's like a succinct summary of like
why we think quantum mechanics is true
so those are the ones that sort of come
to mind i definitely lean toward uh
nonfiction myself and i do i do have a
signed copy
of
r for data science somewhere here that
uh that had the wickham sign which i
like a lot sometimes i just you know
like to produce through that
but that's what i've got
i definitely lean towards non-fiction i
um
uh
like leadership books and continuous
improvements so i love jim collins
series of books i think i could read
those multiple times
um
and then the more data science book that
i read sort of recently was business
data science by matt taddy
which i thought he does a fantastic job
of going pretty deep into and it's all
all the examples are in r
he does a fantastic job bridging between
this is what your output looks like and
this is what it means in your statistics
class and this is how you would use it
if you were working with a stakeholder
right so he does an awesome job
balancing so i'm gonna write it in the
in the um in the chat but i highly
recommend it to everyone on here you
just mentioned like a business focus
book and it reminded me that um my
leadership team and i
just read this together
prediction machines
and um you know as a data scientist
you're not going to really learn a lot
about what ai can do but what this
really was good at was framing like what
is ai and that's why it's called
prediction machines because it's like
the way to talk about stakeholders is
what these things do
is make predictions make really accurate
predictions depending on
um what it is that you're doing and if
you think about that if you think about
it that way now you can think okay what
do i have in my business that could
benefit from having really accurate
predictions made what if predictions are
cheap based on you know basic economics
what does that mean for future
predictions and this was a really good
way to talk about
what we could do with data science with
my executive team so i'd recommend an
exercise like that it was helpful for us
i think um and you could
start like a book club for the community
i think that would be super super fun
that would be cool yeah
i just looked at that book paul and you
can i just want to let everyone know you
can buy it on target.com
[Laughter]
like if we go anywhere my kids are like
we're going to target them yep that's
where we're going
tatiana asked a great question in the
chat too um could i pass the mic over to
you to have you asked that
sure uh but my first question is what
was it predictive modeling the book the
book oh this book is called uh
prediction machines
that's the cover
yep
all right so
um
and that's by um
it's got three it's got three authors
yeah that i'm going that i will just
completely butcher if i try to say them
so i'll let you google
for you i feel like so
yeah
um okay so as from as far as my question
uh and uh eli is also waiting on answer
is basically no pressure
basically uh with your plans to
implement analytics and power bi across
the organization uh one of the bigger
challenges is to
set i guess adequate adoption rates and
then develop a strategy
around it and i'm not i don't want to
ask for the strategy because it's
probably ongoing but what are your
thoughts on how to
are there any mental models that you
adopt or
uh what are the main thoughts around uh
some pitfalls or uh some small wins that
you can make at the beginning like
anything you can share on that
so are you asking about really how to be
successful with like the implementation
of something like power bi is that what
you're asking yeah well uh the analytics
in general right how do you uh well
depending on your goals because i joined
a bit later but
if your goal is make the organization
data driven or if your goal is increase
power bi use depending on your adoption
targets um
right so so i guess our goal so if i
back up and look um i think you need to
have an integrated strategy from the top
down i think that's very important
that's one of the things that our
company has been working on
um over the you know over the past uh
year especially since we've got the new
it organization in place and one of
those
one of those um strategic initiatives is
make database decisions well then you
have to understand like what does that
mean like what does it mean to make
database decisions well
the way that we think about that is it
needs to be um very easy
to to get that and to use it if it's
hard to do you're not going to do it and
it has to come from a source of truth
that everyone could understand
and it has to be um
it can't be locked down to a specific
platform so that's why you might have
heard me talk earlier about web-based
web-based web-based you know i don't
want someone to have to have a certain
program on their computer everything has
a web browser right so if you're on your
phone in the middle of the store i want
you to be able to pull up something that
someone on my team made and get an
answer from it so
that sort of philosophy that connects to
like the executive
kpi of database decisions is what drives
the implementation of something like
power bi or of like our studio team so
when we're making tools
it's not about making some cool thing
that the data scientist thinks is cool
which you know i like to do that too
it's really about making sure
you're connected to the people who need
to be making database decisions and
making sure that that's what you're
doing
because you don't have their job you
don't live their world and they know
more about what they need than you do
so
that sort of philosophy comes all the
way through really how we're
implementing the tools to get to the
result that we want right we don't want
a bunch of people just making a bunch of
cool things that doesn't really go
anywhere we want
strategic sort of surgical
um collaborative
kpi based tools being made
between analysts and the business that
drive the goal of database decision
making
all right so it sounds like um it's
mostly sticking to the top-down rate
strategy making sure that you develop
the appropriate kpis before you roll out
the strategy and then make it accessible
and avoid data silos
absolutely i feel like i should add like
what i said might sound like it's a
little bit um
i want to do that but i also don't want
to be uh restrictive like if someone has
a great idea for some cool thing that no
one's asked for
that's awesome like let's like we'll do
that and we'll and we'll pitch it and
we'll see if it connects so i i don't
want to give the impression that i'm
like you can only work on the things
that meet these like
we want to have strategy but we want to
be agile as well so i think there's room
for both of those things
how do you prioritize those kpis then or
decide like what the team's working on
first
so we've uh
we've been coming from
what you might call a more traditional
i.t setup where
you know folks get tickets and folks
solve that problem and then
they think um that you know they've
they've done 10 tickets today and that's
and then that's good and it is good but
really sometimes you've got to step back
and say
why am i getting that ticket what what's
the real need um
you know our cio allen has this thing
where he says you really gotta ask why
five times right like you've got to get
to that base level of what is happening
what is the real business need and the
other thing is you know what what people
what people want what they think they
want and what they really need are
usually three completely different
things right so
we we've tried to move into this
organizational structure where there are
people
whose real really job it is to be
business liaisons with different folks
around the business so that we can make
sure it's not just doing tickets it's
not just um
solving immediate technical needs it's
really making sure oh someone asked me
for a report and i give them the report
you know the old way of thinking is you
know that's great i'm done but now
someone asked me for a report well why
do you want that oh it's because i'm
trying to answer this question oh well
to answer that question i think you
actually need these four reports and i
think we can automate all of that into
one shiny application so i think instead
of giving you this report that you then
go spend 40 hours of work to update
we're going to give you a url that
solves your problem forever and we would
never have known that if we didn't have
these business relationships so to
directly answer rachel what you asked is
through those relationships and through
that understanding of what the business
needs and the communication with the
business
we have a platform where it's completely
transparent where we say based on
what we know from each other here's what
we're doing and if there's a problem
there we're going to talk about that and
we all get to say that's not what we
should be doing or that is so it's
collaborative in that effect
awesome thanks paul
yeah just then sent a note to our team
to clip that i love that
um
or mubanga apologies if i
mispronounce your name i see you asked a
question earlier on
what is that 20 that gives you the 80
bang in your day-to-day role
would you want to jump in and add any
other context there
yeah i just wanted to find out like
because what um
the teams are talking about is quite
interesting data services
so i wanted to understand like uh
like
the 80 20 rule like obviously there's
the 20 that gives them the edge in the
80 percent of the output so i wanted to
understand that aspect of of what
they're doing basically the high level
um i guess the two things that come to
mind there are um
well there's there's the boring stuff
there's the there's the data
infrastructure and pipelines and access
to build tools that we think a lot about
and that we don't we don't have in a
place that we
that we're happy with today but that
we're that we're moving to
and and as we
excuse me as we sort of make progress
you know that's
that's the amount of effort that just
really takes off like it really drives
what you can do
with your analytics whenever it's not
hard to get to get to your data and then
i think the other sort of big driver of
impact you know less effort bigger
impact is the communication with
business that i just
talked about with the last question
um you know i'm probably just
meeting the same drum that a lot of
folks have i know there's been a lot of
talk about
well actually i guess the talk is really
good about communicating results and
that's very important um but i guess
really what i'm talking about is
communicating what you're doing and why
and what the business thinks about that
and getting on the same page with that
is massively successful because it just
opens up well i mean it makes everyone
happier like the people feel like they
have a say they know why they're doing
what they're doing they know the
business impact of what they're doing
you're solving root problems instead of
solving tickets or higher level problems
that aren't really getting to the need
of the matter
and it's a relatively low effort for the
output that you get you know talk to
talk to people be people first
understand the needs i think that's key
and also maybe uh just a quick note uh
developing a high level strategy uh or
some framework like north star metric
right where you have this
and then you have lagging indicator
leading indicators and then how you
structure the overall and bring to the
absolute
we're big on those indicators we're big
on uh performance metrics uh from the
business
um okrs we're implementing okrs to try
to understand how we're tracking our key
results and goals yes all of this is
that strategy is also really important
thank you elias see you have a follow-up
question on the implementation strategy
would you want to ask that one yeah
thank you rachel um hey paul so i did
have a follow-up question
about
um implementation and trying to get
buy-in from teams that might be a little
hesitant
um and
some pointers around that for teams that
are hesitant they might be like related
adopters related adapters to like the
new analytic tools and technology so if
you have any pointers around getting
over that hump
yeah um i what i've done in the past is
try to show small wins that are very
directed to those individuals right so
if you if you can figure out that
there's a thorn in someone's side that's
going to be a three-hour shiny app that
takes that problem away forever even if
that's not a business priority if it
doesn't connect to a kpi
just do it and give it to them and
they're going to be like
whoa
you can you can do that okay because i
think there's hearing and then they're
seen
and so i think being able to
solve small personal problems for
someone even if it's not a huge you know
you can do some stuff in r that's not
exactly data science but it might just
be automation of some manual work that
takes up a huge swath of someone's time
when you show you're interested in
solving their problems they tend to come
along for for the rest of the strategy
that's that's that's the technique that
i've used in the past
thank you paul
yeah um
tony i see you asked a question about
plumber would you want to ask that one
live
sure it wasn't really about plumber what
i wanted to know was you talked about
integrating power bi into your process
and i actually recently just last week
someone approached me about that
and i don't know much about power bi so
i was wondering if you could talk about
the integration of those two tools i
gave an example of my question of are
you going to serve data from plumber for
power bi to consume but that's just a
guess because i don't know anything
about it
right so
i haven't used plumber um
i think i've used it in one project so
not using it too much
i do use pins a lot to write data frames
back to rstudio connect but that mostly
just serves um
r and python users
um
one thing i mentioned etl in our
markdown i mentioned living in our
markdown one of the great things about
that is
i can have a script that uses sql
queries a bunch of stuff um
brings it in uses python and r to munch
it and then uses like odbc packages to
push it back
into a data science table that can then
be consumed by
power bi
or by our users so
that's kind of the way that we're
sharing data currently um trying to
build what we're calling sort of
enterprise-ready data sources one source
of truth like if you look at your data
needs you could probably bucket them
down into x buckets and you can try to
build something at the base level that
works for everyone from those buckets
and then that becomes like the source of
truth for those data sources and then
you can write them in such a way where
power bi or shiny or dash or whatever
users can can access that that data now
when i think about the future where i
have power bi fully automated and i have
um shiny applications and i have like uh
model outputs and stuff like that
yeah i would probably use something like
a plumber api to make sure that everyone
could grab those to integrate into their
apps that'd probably be one solution we
just haven't gotten there yet
okay thanks
i mean it sounds like you're pushing to
a database so that way those tools can
use their built-in database connectivity
to
get you
you got it whenever my powerball user
opens and sees connections
i want them to have that you know it
might be a table that came from our
process but to them it's going to be
just a source they can use to build what
they need right
yeah okay thanks
thanks paul
um i see a few people sent in questions
and said they're in a busy office right
now so i'll read them
but one was how often do you revisit a
model that's already in production do
you have any fixed cycle or depending on
need
so um
when i build something like that i
always build
some some sort of flex dashboard or
shiny application that monitors
performance for that model something i
can quickly go to and look at and see
what's going on
and i i'm kind of that nerd that likes
to go look at that a lot so i tend to
just naturally
you know during my morning coffee look
and see what's going on i i don't really
have like a schedule or anything of
course if i hear a problem from a user
like i feel like uh
there's something wrong here i i go i go
look at it then but um
so yeah i think that's the answer
thank you and then one just
clarification question they asked um not
sure if this was already discussed but
how do you host your shiny apps to the
business users
oh yeah we use we use our studio
team so we have our studio connect on
prem
so we also have our studio um
workbench
so a lot of development in workbench
where we have all of our
handy-dandy connections and protocols
sort of set up
so you can pretty quickly bang on a
shiny app hit the hit the blue publish
button push it to connect and then you
can pull it up you can quickly set a
vanity url
set um who can see it who can't and then
we share that
we are working on what our solution is
going to be but we really really we
really don't want every user to come
land on connect to like find their app
but there's some really cool ways like
you can you can use blog down for
example to build something custom
there's a new package to come out it's
not the connect api package it's called
something else
that lets you pretty quickly build a
landing page on connect
that that is a sort of one-stop shop for
your content
we also use um echo internally so we've
toured with building a data science
landing page for those tools but so
anyway if they're sort of sharing with
the user which is easy you should just
send them a link but then there's like
how do you let people come sort of find
and
that we're still toying with but it's
probably going to be some sort of r
developed connect hosted
website that lets people come and
explore the data science products that
are there
great thank you um there's a question
from earlier sorry i was just scrolling
up to find um was any management any
management or leadership principles that
you could share
management or leadership principles well
you know i mentioned earlier being
people focused
i think that's really important
i think especially
in current day with
pandemic
supply chains
child care um
people losing people to covid you really
you really have to remember that we're
all people first we're people that are
coming to work so i i try to remember
that every day
i think you also have to i think you
have to have a culture of it's okay to
fail actually it's good to fail um fail
fast fail often uh get get to the thing
that that works
meet people where they are um give give
them the tools they need to grow find
out what they care about and like and
try to give them more of that um
celebrate success and learn from failure
um
so yeah i don't know i guess that's my
laminated card of like
bullet point leadership quotes
yeah
thank you i see shannon you had a
follow-up question there if you want to
just ask that too
yeah sure i was just curious
if your management and leadership came
naturally to you or if that was
something you worked towards through
mentorship or reading books
oh um
well i i've always been sort of a people
person of course that doesn't mean
you're a good leader or a good manager
managing is such a is such a different
thing and uh to directly answer your
question when i went from
what was called an in
an individual contributor to a people
leader at my previous job
thankfully i was in a i was in an
organization that recognized the
difference there if if you're a person
who is a especially if you're a person
who really cares about your work you're
a go-getter you're typing code all the
time you're giving products you're
solving problems you're seeing the
fruits of your labor directly when you
hand someone a link and you're like and
they're like oh my god i can do this
great thing now that i couldn't do
before thank you so much when you go
from that to now your job is to manage
these x people
and provide them with success and clear
the path for them and make them rock
stars it is a
it's being thrown into the deep end of
the swimming pool and you're no longer
getting that personal feedback that you
used to get from solving problems
yourself so i was lucky enough to have
i mean i think it was about six months
of different hr led
trainings and seminars and resources
given to me
to understand that change and understand
um really
you're not you don't just have your
lever now you have a you have a lever
for the team and you and you have more
impact but it's in a different way and
the thing that's important to your
day-to-day completely changes and i
think i would have struggled with that a
lot longer than i did i mean i did
struggle with it even with even with the
help but i think i would have struggled
with it even longer had i not been given
those resources so i mean that's
probably an important note that as you
if you're a person who is a data
scientist and you see yourself
becoming a leader one day um just just
keep that in mind that it's gonna be a
change it's going to feel weird it's
going to be a shift and honestly not
everyone likes that like i've worked
with people who got a taste of that and
decided they'd rather be a data science
based technical leader that's what they
wanted to do instead of being a more
people leader
it really depends on what you like but i
do think that you you can learn with
resources of course to to be better at
it just just like anything
thanks paul
um tony i'm not gonna try and summarize
your question i'm just going to call on
you to ask that one
fine i don't want to like dominate the
discussion but i heard paul say
something which
triggered a um
a thought from we you talked about using
the pins package a lot and i've seen our
studio kind of push that package and it
looks real real nice and this is all
great
but our problem with it is that then
we're storing data in connect
and i don't believe we at least we don't
believe right now connect is hardened
enough for things like our crown jewel
data it's not a dial chemical so there's
quite a bit of
variety of data that we deal with right
and some data businesses consider crown
jewels so they don't want they want to
know exactly who and how is accessing
that data and so
we have not i would say validated
connect as a means of a data repository
so we use it to host things that reach
out to a database and then we can
use things like run as user to ensure
the connection and you know we're
passing our you know cabros credentials
to the database so we know who is the
person who access that data
so how do you guys deal with
more sensitive data in in connect and do
you have a
kind of a policy around what data you
can pin and whether you can't and how do
you how do you like deal with that right
and you know if our studio wants to jump
in you know anyone there and tell me how
they'll make pins
more
um secure and i'm not saying it's not
secure it's just like access to it is
kind of
you know i control it right so anyway if
you could talk about pins and how you
guys are using that
um
yeah so if i guess i'm being completely
honest you know we're we're working on
our overall data strategy as a part of
this transition going from the
traditional um tools and techniques that
we're using into
the new tools and techniques that we're
using um
currently pins are great because you can
sort of work within rstudio workbench
and you can build an end-to-end etl app
collaborative
pipeline and push those things and host
them and have them all work without
really needing to uh pull resources from
from somewhere else
i get your point about data security um
i mean i know that you can just like any
other object in connect you can control
if it's open access if it's by group
like we use ada active directory for our
our studio connect instance so we can
control by individual or by group who
can see any object like including pins
now of course you know it admin will be
able to see that kind of like anything
else
sorry i just heard something um
upstairs i'm not sure what that is
anyway maybe someone's at my door um so
you know we have our traditional data
warehouse that we're using to save
and store and work off most of our
you're calling crown jewel data sources
a lot of the stuff we have in pins right
now are sort of intermediate steps to
get us to an application or get us to a
model i don't know what the future looks
like for um
for pins data storage long term i mean i
doubt that's going to be like our data
warehouse though that's kind of not
that's not what it is in my mind and
then i guess our studio can jump in if
they have another
thought about that
i of course can't speak to it as well as
our engineers would be able to but i'm
wondering if you could use environment
variables
with pins as well to make that more
secure but i'm just going to share a
helpful link on pins too
i think that's not the real issue the
real issue is you have to have a policy
around what data can and can't go there
sure so i think our decision was we just
don't put data into connect you know as
like a policy right which then we don't
use pins and we try to find you know a
different approach for it and
i didn't know if you guys had that
policy defined like this is you know
please don't put you know detailed
schematics of unknown to the world
reactors into pins not saying you can
i'm just an example right please don't
put like the newest billion dollar
catalyst molecule structure into pins
right so we don't have that right and so
it's kind of it's kind of hard to define
that so that's why i was wondering have
you defined any policy around it or
right now it's kind of a free brawl for
data science and you'll deal with that
you know later yeah that's it's it's
definitely the latter like i i
understand what you're saying and we
we um our security team is very um
worried a lot about everything
security based so whenever we brought
our studio team in and we talked about
connect and who has access and what's
being stored there we had a lot of
conversations about what we were doing
um so i guess there's sort of an
unspoken rule of certain things aren't
going on connect
we don't have a policy but again it's
it's something that
we know we need and we want to have but
we just we just haven't got to yet
i think we're all in the same boat then
yeah yeah one of those things
lots of conversations
right that's right
i'm scrolling through to see if there's
any questions i miss so feel free to
jump in
if you have anything that you want to
ask um one question i will ask you paul
because i'm trying to figure out how to
create a resource for this but
i've i've talked to a lot of people who
are in like the very early stages of
kind of like being our champion and
maybe making some presentation for their
architecture review design board or
whatever internal review process they
have
and i
am just wondering how you actually went
about doing that whether
at your last role or or now
to get our studio approved
um right so
i i started off like i mentioned earlier
by doing things with free open source
versions locally so first it was like
hey can i get rstudio it's open source
you know here's what it does it's an ide
and that's usually short you can do that
and then can i download you know
packages approved packages on crayon and
that's usually not a problem either at
least it wasn't for me um and then once
you have that i mean you you basically
had everything right now you can install
our markdown shiny you can you can you
can pull in local data you can show a
shiny application running locally you
can do like i mentioned earlier and make
a flex dashboard and send that out as an
html file to people so they can see what
that looks like
and then you can um
build a strategy i remember making slide
decks i think i've shown some of these
slide decks art studio actually where i
was like basically said hey here's how
you do things now you know here's the
current state diagram of how you do
analytics how people consume them and
here's what you could do if we had some
set of data science tools and then i
would show literal examples of that and
then i would say and here's what that
would look like to acquire and so that's
how i convinced people to to give me
those tools so that i could do better
work
thank you that's that's really helpful
so it's like actual
slide deck presentation that you brought
to yep nr
yeah i did it nr like knitted it to pdf
and i would even say like you know the
slide deck was made in r like there's
lots of i remember a presentation i gave
on our markdown they just talked about
just the incredible you know swiss army
knife capabilities of it and sort of
what it could do stuff it could replace
ways we could use it instead of other
things that we use now um
so communicating value and then using
i i think one time i called it like a
stair-step approach right like if you
can get rstudio or r and get access to
cram packages on your work machine
and use local data sources well then you
can sort of stair step that out
you know you can find a
you can find a business need that
someone needs to be solved and you can
solve it better
right like someone needs an analysis
like i remember when i was it when i was
at bf like someone at someone had this
data that was coming out of like um an
hplc which is which is a chemical
analysis where you put liquid in this
machine and then you get this output of
all the chemistry that's there right and
they're like hey we need to understand
descriptive statistics for these
chemical compounds and we need like an
ovarian and we need this this and the
second time she asked me i just built a
shiny app
and i and i actually gave the local code
just on her machine and i was like the
next time you do this you know press
this run button and then it looks like a
web page upload your file and everything
you just asked me to do will just be
done and then that person was like
holy crap that's amazing and then they
talked about it to everybody and then
next thing you know you have individuals
coming to you saying oh you know and
then that gets the attention of
leadership as well and so that's you
know you can sort of work at that ground
level as well solve problems for
individuals like i mentioned earlier
then while you're doing that that
becomes part of the example that you lay
out in your presentation of like look
this is why hey we can do this b i have
been doing it see here's the feedback
from that and d here's the solution to
make this
you know
a real thing we're doing instead of a
thing that i'm like covertly doing
on my laptop but you may have to break a
few
a few rules now i'm not telling you to
like disregard your policies or whatever
but if i'm being honest like i probably
did a couple of things that certain
people in it didn't really like
and but i'm the kind of person that i
think you break a few windows because
you know the new house is going to be
awesome and that's just the way that it
is and so that's what i did and it is
more awesome now so i'm okay with that
decision
that's awesome thank you paul sorry i'm
like i'm beating this question but i'm
just really trying to understand how i
give people advice for this when they
ask me how other people do it
but that presentation that you give was
that to
leadership or was it in that from the
beginning as well or
so at the time at the time that i did
that this was in my previous role
because i kind of came in at this level
here so i didn't have to worry about it
uh but then it was it was to um my
immediate management who who took that
up which eventually became an i.t
conversation because when you start
asking which got me connected to i.t
because you know depending on where you
work in your organization you might not
have a connection to i.t
so
that's another thing that you need to
that you need to get so i would even
recommend like
it might be hard in today's environment
too with remote working but if you can
try to uh you know set up some lunches
with folks you don't know in it reach
out to those folks
talk about analytics try to meet people
who work on those teams building those
connections is also helpful for that but
from what i did it was immediate
management which went up that chain
which eventually got to this point where
hey we want to do this and they were
told cool talk to it and then it kind of
became this collaborative discussion
about about getting it implemented and i
even faced questions like we were using
tableau at the time and you know i got
asked like why do we need this we have
to have low and so i put together a
whole another thing about how well you
have these analysts professionals the
temple is awesome for them but then you
have data science
and here's like a table of what each
thing is good and not good at and why
you really need both of them to solve
this problem and that was like the final
thing i did that got the check signed
thank you so much there's
actually a question about around tableau
as well someone just asked how do you
think about when and why you'd want to
use something like power bi or tableau
versus when you'd use shiny or our
markdown
yeah so honestly i am now you know i
i'm incredibly biased like we all are um
i i prefer
code based solutions for lots of reasons
i think they're much more flexible i
think you can integrate all of the
awesome things that are in that
ecosystem right so in shiny any r
package any r function all the custom
functions i've written in my custom
packages
any new model any new statistical method
or theory that comes out is going to be
in our right i mean that's that's what
the programming language sort of is for
and then i can immediately use that
stuff in anything that i make it's all
code based i can collaborate with code i
can do things like pull requests i can
do things like have a git repo i can do
things like have it be transparent have
to be reproducible have it be completely
re you know you can make it again with a
button press you can compile it all over
again because again it's code based i
think that those benefits are just
they're hard to match with a gooby based
system just because it is a gui based
system now where i think tools like that
are helpful is not everyone's a coder
not everyone's a data scientist there
are lots of very smart capable analysts
who know their business know what the
business needs but they don't know are
and they need something again to get to
that modern web-based output
single-click consumption model without
needing to write code and so that's why
in my mind it's a parallel
service diagram of two different paths
for those type of folks and for data
science types of folks but there are
also lines going between them right i
want those models to be used in the
tableau
workbook in the power bi workbook
there's collaboration there there's the
same sort of data infrastructure we're
working off of but
there's two different parallel paths for
that reason
but if i had my druthers though like if
i say i was starting my own company i
would absolutely be biased toward let's
do everything with code
thank you paul and i know we're getting
to the top of the hour but there's a few
more questions if that's okay
sure yeah okay
um
one was recommendations for someone to
transition into data science um so they
said they've taken r
python training but they don't use it in
their current role
how do you get better at coding i highly
recommend literally working through r
for data science from cover to cover if
you if you can work through that book
and you understand everything in that
book
you're ready for uh in my opinion for an
entry level job in data science if you
can show that you like if a new
candidate came to me and they
um
had a github repo with some projects
they worked on for fun like i remember
when flex dashboard first came out like
you know 84 years ago and i wanted to
learn it and i just had some
i knew that census data had like or
there was a package for like baby names
and i was like and i was having a child
and i was like what if i made some shiny
app using flex dashboard to understand
trends about baby names and so
that's how i learned so i did that and i
had it in github and every project i did
i tried to keep there so eventually you
have this really cool portfolio so even
if you're not doing it in your job
you have work that you can show someone
who's hiring you
that um you are interested in it and
that you know what you're doing and
really like i think that's all that
matters at the end of the day can you
show competency um in that area and i
think that having that passion of like
i'm gonna learn this i'm gonna build
something cool on the weekends or in the
evening also shows me that you're kind
of the person i want to hire because
i like passionate people who love what
they do and clearly you are because
you've got this cool github repo of all
the packages that you like
thank you i think that actually kind of
answers this next question as well but
was um in terms of hiring what makes
data science data science candidates
stand out or how do you hire for your
team
yeah yeah i i'm pretty um
i'm open like a brown formula we had a
python arm make so we all collaborated
it's great i'm open to that now too but
i think showing me competency and data
science um
again i'm biased toward our you know we
use our studio team as our sort of data
science platform showing me that that
you are comfortable in our markdown you
know tidy verse um showing me code
showing you projects you've done in
github there's also this piece though
that i feel can be lacking i think that
data science is so popular and it has
blown up so much that
some i have run into people who are
really good at that but they really
don't have a sound statistical theory
and i don't think there's a substitute
for
having just a basic understanding of of
statistics like what is this regression
model thing that you're doing what
assumptions does it have why does it
work like what's the central limit
theorem um how would you guide someone
if they had a data set and they didn't
know how to analyze it and i think you'd
have to have that other background so i
think that's something for folks to keep
in mind if they don't come from like a
stats background that that's something
they should at least think about doing
not it's not just the r and the python
and the packages it's also
knowing the stats and how to use them
and how to communicate them to the
business that's also huge like like one
day like if you use logistic regression
one day think about how would you
explain to like the vp of marketing what
an odds ratio is
like honestly think about that it's it's
not it's not intuitive right like try to
get good at doing stuff like that and
you'll be very very valuable
that's great thank you so much paul yeah
i should have asked this earlier but is
there a question that you'd like to ask
to the audience as well
on the spot no i don't think i have one
no i was so worried about um being good
at answering questions that i didn't
think of one
i should say that next time but um
i i don't think there's any other
questions i do would just want to take a
second to pause to make sure if i missed
anything that feel free to unmute
yourself and and speak up
but one question we always like to ask
at the end paul is if people want to get
in touch with you what's the best way is
it linkedin
or twitter
yeah i would say find me on linkedin
you can connect with me there and you
can direct message me there as well
frank i see you unmuted i take that as
you raising your hand
uh
i was just gonna throw in there um paul
when are we getting our free samples do
you need our addresses
uh yeah
wouldn't that be great i'll have to
check with marketing sales see if i'm
allowed i think there are also some laws
around shipping alcohol i'm not really
sure but you know whenever you're at
target next you can probably pick up
some evan williams or elijah craig there
if you're in one that sells liquor
okay well we all get together sometime
in in person maybe at our studio
conference
we can have a nice little uh whiskey
tasting there
yeah maybe we can get a heaven hill
sponsorship for the for the drinks i'll
see what i can do
well
thank you so much paul i really
appreciate your time and and sharing all
your insights with us and thank you all
for joining too hopefully see you all
next week same time same place have a
great rest of the day
you